I could only imagine the cocktail of
garbage inside your phone right no lies
you tell I just want to apologize to all
just ladies ok guys you probably asked
girls to marry you like I never say this
I never say this I could win should see
myself marrying you could a guy like
this break your heart and the answer is
of course and he will what's up
everybody welcome to stupid questions
with Chris de Stefano I'm with Rachel
Feinstein you can see her special to
stand-ups on Netflix that she's got a
good podcast called three girls one
Keith all right here's a stupid question
what's the dumbest lie you've ever told
your parents oh here's a good one okay
my mom found like a hickey on my neck
just the biggest dumbest it was like
obvious and I told my mother that a wolf
bit me what did your mom believe it no
she would always say this by allied
Church because I'll please Rachel I
lived in California in the 1960s
that's no wolf that's a goddamn hickey
I've been around the block which is such
a gross thing to hear your mom like no
one wants to hear your mom be like I've
been passed around I have a stupid
question for you okay did you have a
nickname growing up well when I was a
kid people used to call me Mayo kind of
mayonnaise well no I was like I was a
basketball player and I was like the
only white kid so like my friends my
black friends would call me Mayo oh then
he used to call me gums cuz I was all
gums I'd really just I had like I
actually had gingivitis like it was like
a dental issue because my gums were
always bleeding there but Chrissy gums
are like horseface something like that
kids all that they're so extremely cruel
they'll find a thing you weren't you
never even occurred to be self-conscious
about like I still remember this guy
like walking me home from school in days
like how come you've got that little
thing on the top of your thighs it's
like extra fat I've never forgotten
wesley's dog sentence but you know still
now and I look in the mirror I'm like
add that little extra pad that wasn't
careful a little cherry of fat on top
and also who insult someone and that
makes them answer for he's like how come
you got back
next to the question what's the weirdest
thing you've seen in somebody else's
home oh my friend that I grew up with
her dad had a toothpick dispenser next
to his okay
couch and sometimes he wouldn't be able
to find his toothpicks when I go over
there and you go where the hell's my
Spencer we're in Hell smile Spencer
that's all he wanted he just wanted his
toothpick now with that as a young woman
make you feel extremely uncomfortable to
be alone in the house with that with
that father I remember one time he was
on his way to 7-eleven and he goes you
girls want anything it was just me and
my friend and I was like no I'm okay
eight he goes I'm just gonna get me
hooker in a hot dog like a couple of
ten-year-old hooker in a hot dog that's
a good t-shirt next to the question
chunky heels or chunky guys I like a
chunky guy nice yes I like a little
extra weight I like a little thickness
in a man yeah well your fiance's a
little thick guy yeah I like I've even
shaped though I like to see a thick
thigh on a man because I don't want to
be the bigger one I don't be like big
reader kind of lumber and over and if a
guy's a little out of shape I feel like
that makes me feel more confident too I
want to bring like the treats to the
hookup yeah I got like I got some weight
on me like going the pool I'll keep my
shirt on you know just have my tits get
wet beautiful no my god who told you
that people made a lot of money here
hell yeah all right thank you so much
for being a part of showed you have a
good time
I did yeah all right so you know for
being a part of my show I wanted to give
you a stupid gift yes I want to give you
this and this is just aqua jewelry like
your mother wears you know what I'm
worth it yeah so thank you for watching
stupid questions with Krista Stefano my
daughter Rachel Feinstein stupid
questions uglier than anything I've ever
seen
you